and we're joined by 12 year old avi manu
mishra
after finishing the chessable masters
and i'll be
i'm going to say congratulations with
that win you got in round 14.
thank you thank you yeah it was it was
an amazing game but it was it was
pull-ups ups and downs but yeah in the
end i managed to win that yeah
it's it's a dream come true to play in
this event and play against the players
i've been looking up to for a very long
time they're all very very strong and
i'm very happy about my performance oh
yeah what has it been like these
three days playing chess for many many
hours of course
against these elite players yes it's
very fun
as as their resourcefulness is simply
amazing like
in two of my games one game against
mamedyarov and one game against a divan
they both were in worse positions but
the way the game the
game changed completely it shows i have
a lot of a lot to learn
apart from that i mean these days were a
bit difficult for me as
i've never really earlier played rapid
and for the last
several months i've been playing only
classical and the yeah the focus was
unclassical
of course but then in round 14 here
you're winning the game against
world number 21 he's a super gm
pentala hari krishna how do you imagine
you would be able to do that
i mean i've been always trying to but
yeah it was
it was amazing i mean it was i wasn't
yeah it was full of ups and downs india
in the end i managed to win it was
i wasn't really sure that i would be
able to win this game can you can you
take us through what you were feeling
what you were thinking especially
towards the end there because what a
game it was
yeah so towards the start it was in the
opening i had like a slightly
a slightly better position and as the
game went on i feel i feel like at some
point i was winning but then
i let it slip and it it reached to an
equal ending and
and there he he uh my d-pawn he let my
d-pawn run and yeah then there was some
there was a mistake and i was very happy
of course after
after i won and of course you said it
many times it was
of course about getting experience in
this tournament but
what does it mean to go away from it
with also a win
yeah i mean it feels great to
finally out of after playing all the
worlds that lead to finally get one win
against them
definitely and will you celebrate now i
i know it's not too late over there in
the u.s
yes definitely how will you celebrate
i mean okay for the rest of the day
probably not don't play any other
don't practice any other just for now
i'm sorry i'm very thankful for the
organizers to have invited me this is
this was an amazing opportunity for me
um yeah i know congratulations on your
victory we were following that and we
were very impressed
so what is next for you do you have any
tournaments lined up
oh oh maybe we lost him a little bit of
oh there you are
problem it's back uh yeah so did you
hear ivanka's question
no i'm sorry i wasn't able to i was just
asking what is next on the horizon for
you
probably after a few months i'm going to
play some probably gibraltar or
something and yeah i'm going to keep my
my next goal is 2700 and finally it's
world champion
wow you can do it have a menu when you
look
when you look back on this tournament
what are they going to be the two or
three main highlights or the main things
you're going to take away
the the resourcefulness of top players
like in my game against my media
it was a very strange opening and from
the way he the way he
changed the height of the game was
simply amazing and yeah
i'm very happy about my three draws and
when
yeah are you are you feeling inspired
also after this uh
we know you love working with chess but
even more inspired maybe
yes definitely all right i'll be manu
it's been
so fantastic to follow you in this
tournament we're so happy for you
getting that win and getting that
experience
thank you so much for joining us